hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to the 10th part of one of the
most successful chess series on youtube
dirty chess tricks
now as per the request from many of my
subscribers i am going to concentrate
some of the very aggressive opening from
the black perspective
the most frequent opening which is used
from master level to the beginners is
the italian game which start with the
move order e4 e5 knight to f3 knight to
c6 and bishop to c4
now here there are two main moves from
the black perspective one is bishop to
c5 and the other is knight to f6
but the problem with the move knight to
f6 is
if white wants white can immediately
start attacking the black king via the
moon knight to g5
i'm not saying this opening is bad for
black
but
white has many great attacking ideas
such as fried liver attack or the lolly
attack
not to mention there are many gambits
exist in this line
so all in all
you need to know a lot of theory as a
black
and apart from that your defensive skill
should be very good
so that's why this opening attracts many
players especially
players below the 1600 because they can
crush their opponents very easily
but as a black this is exactly we want
because here i'm going to propose the
move which is not proposed
in many books and videos that is the
modify
but instead of that we are going to play
a stunner that is
bishop to c5
bam
and
if white has seen this position first
time
he will consider that you are completely
full of the noob
who doesn't have any idea what's going
on on the board
i still remember when first time i
played this opening against a rated
player
he give me a glance and like he's saying
inside are you serious man is this guy
is really a good rated player
but nevertheless
this opening has a big venom
now the obvious move over here is knight
captures f7
it's a nature looking move and
what can be wrong because
it's attacking the queen in a rook
and what is black is going to do about
it
before we move on i like to mention two
important points over here
the first thing is
in this lecture i'm not covering the
whole theory
i'm going to concentrate only the tricks
and traps exist in the structural
counter attack
and the second thing is
as a black you need to prepare yourself
for sacrificing the heavy material
the simple reason is in many cases these
three queen side pieces of the white
will never come into the picture that
means initially white is three piece
down
so
it gives us a license to become hell
loose
after the move knight captures f7
here comes the second dazzling move that
is
bishop captures f2
bam
if white is shocked with your first move
he will be double shocked with this move
because he will definitely wonder what's
going on on the board
first of all it's a check so here white
has two obvious moves either white
capture that bishop or just run away
in the first possibility we are going to
have a look what will happen after king
captures f2
after king captures f2
we are going to play the obvious move
that is knight to e4 with a check
and now king has few squares to go
amongst them
king to g1 and king to e3 are the most
critical one
but first we need to know what we should
do if the king goes to the other squares
so the first move i need to consider is
king to f3 after king to f3 the obvious
move is queen to f6 with a check
and if white has come this far
then there is no sense of playing any
other moves
so white has to accept this knight
and now queen to f4 is not clear
because white king has a chance to
escape so instead of that i'm going to
propose the second move that is the move
d5 and this is more or less
confirm the black victory
now please note king cannot capture this
pawn because if king captures d5 then
there's a checkmate in two
you can find it your own i'm showing you
right now so we have knight check and if
the king goes to the e4 then queen f4 is
a checkmate
and if king goes to the c5 then queen b6
is a checkmate
so
it's very obvious that
bishop has to capture this pawn so
bishop captures d5
and now we are going to play queen to f4
check
so the only move is king to d3
afterwards
queen to d4 check
and after k to e2
we are going to simply snap up that
bishop
we regain our piece and now we are
continuously threatening
two squares that is f7 and g2
but that is not the only threat
if white plays a blunder move that is
knight captures rook
then the whole idea is revealed because
now we are going to play
bishop to g4 and securing king and queen
so those are some of the wonderful traps
exist in king to f3 line
the second move i want to consider is
king to e2
after king to e2 it's not a good square
because now the second knight can join
into the party with the move knight to
d4 check
and once again
the only good square for the white king
is king to e3 because if the king goes
to the d3 then knight to f2 will simply
give a family fork
which cannot be good
so king to e3 is forced
and now we are going to play the move
queen to h4
so idea is very simple
from the next move we want to play
queen to f4 which force king to go to
the d3 and then we'll play knight to f2
accordingly
white has only few responses left
if the very obvious one that is knight
captures h8 then it leads to the
checkmate so it's a quick checkmate let
me go through it queen to f4 check
king to d3
and now
comes our favorite king dance let's
start with the move knight to c5
king to c3 and then the moves are like
this
and finally with the pawn moves we are
checkmating the white king
rather nice
right so that means at this point knight
captures that is prohibited if white
plays d3 we can simply capture this g3
pawn with the knight
so
that leads to the only move left that is
rook to f1
but after this we have the another
stunning move that is the move d5
right now we are not worried about
white capturing the materials instead of
that we are concentrating on the
development
now once again knight captures at h8
will fail because we'll play queen to g5
jack and we can check out by your
computers this is
made in few moves
so very obvious is why it needs to
capture the d5 pawn but after this
we'll play the another winning move that
is bishop to g4 bam
the queen cannot go to the even because
there's a night fork
so the only
counter reply left is g3 but afterwards
the very simple queen to h5
and now
there is no escape
i reached this position in one of my
game my opponent replied over here queen
to e1 but after this i played knight
shack which is a fork
and after
king captures e4 knight captures e1 rope
captures e1
why it doesn't have enough compensation
so the game concluded very very fast so
i played queen to f5 check and after
king to e3 i just played rook to f8 and
my opponent resigned over here
so that is about king to e2
the third move i want to consider is
king to e1 which as a naked eye it looks
ugly move because obvious move is queen
to h4 check
and the only reply left is g3 afterwards
it's very obvious that black is going to
capture that pawn now two replies exist
over here in the first one
if white capture the rook in the corner
then there's an accurate
move order which finished the white off
instantly
so there's a mate in four i'm showing
you right now so it's a knight to e4
with a check
king to e2
queen to f2
king to d3 and now
there are two ways you can checkmate
black king i'm showing you one of them
so knight to b4 check and after king to
e4
queen to f4 is a checkmate so this
patent is coming up more often so you
should remember this pattern
and the second one
instead of catching the rook in the
corner
white capture the knight so h captures
g3 here black will capture the rook
and after bishop to f1 we are going to
play a very simple move but very
effective one
castle
so that pin the knight white has the
only good reply that is queen to e2
but after this we are going to attack
that queen with the move
knight to d4 and after queen to g2
will happily exchange the queen
because the resulting position
will only favor the black so this is a
once again a winning position for black
so that is about king to e1 the last
move left is
king to f1
but once again this cannot be good the
only thing you need to be taken care of
is you cannot play queen to f6 because
that will allow white to play queen to
f3
so instead of that we need to play the
queen to h4 threatening a checkmate on
f2
the only reply left is white needs to
defend those that square with the queen
but however it will play it will not
work out so for example
and the first move
if white plays the move queen to e1 then
there comes the knight check
the only good reply over here is queen
takes knight
and if you count the material over here
black is a clear two piece down
but see the magic
first of all we take this bishop with
the check
and after the move d3
we capture the knight with the check and
after the king moves we just castle on
the king's side
so from two piece down
we now become one point ahead
and
white king is clearly misplaced
once again i can say this is a winning
position for black
now instead of queen to e1 if fight
plays queen to f3
or queen to e2 more or less same story
because we are going to give this check
and
if the queen captures then queen to c4
we already look at this position
and instead of that if the king runs
away for example king to g1
then the simplest is queen check and
after queen to e3
we just capture the special so now we
are threatening two things we are
threatening a checkmate on f1 as well as
threatening to catch the knight
so white is obliged to capture that
night afterwards
we regain our peace and once again
emerge with our winning position